[Music]
the sun is just one of hundreds of
billions of stars in our galaxy
in a way there's nothing very special
about it
it's a fairly ordinary star not
particularly large or bright by stellar
standards
but it's very special to us
the sun makes life on earth possible
cultures across the world and throughout
the ages worship the sun in some ways
modern life has cut us off from the sun
in the developed world we spend 90
percent of our time indoors
and yet the sun is still a powerful
force underpinning our lives
the sun affects our perception of beauty
when people talk of the golden hour that
time just before the sun sets it's a
real thing
the sun isn't actually yellow or orange
or even red
it's all the colors mixed together
when the sun rises or sets in the sky
the shortwave colours green blue and
violet are scattered leaving only the
yellow and the red part of the spectrum
giving that amazing glow
when the sun is high in the sky its blue
waves bounce around which is why the sky
looks blue
and when you see a rainbow that's the
light from the sun separated into all
its magnificent colors
although we talk of the sun rising in
the east and setting in the west that's
not quite true it just seems that way to
us
the sun stays in the same place it's the
earth that rotates on its axis
this movement of the sun is deeply
embedded in our biology
when sunlight enters the eye it sends
signals to a master clock in our brain
called the suprachiasmatic nucleus this
internal clock regulates everything from
when we sleep to how we digest a meal
messing with this finely tuned machine
when we work night shifts or fly across
the world can make us feel pretty rough
even the bluish light from a mobile
phone late at night is enough to disrupt
and confuse our internal body clock
being out of step with the sun affects
our mood and our ability to think
clearly and there's evidence that this
kind of disruption can lead to higher
rates of obesity heart disease diabetes
and even cancer
we're living out of step with the sun
and some scientists say this could be
causing a public health crisis
when the sun's shining studies have
shown that we tip more generously and
are more likely to splash out on luxury
goods
and crime may go down too
one study in the u.s found that when the
clocks go forward for daylight savings
time the number of robberies rapes and
murders went down around 50
the sun is a hell of a force to be
reckoned with
every hour enough sunlight falls on the
earth to power the world for a year
a year
deep in its core at around 15 million
degrees celsius the sun is constantly
fusing hydrogen together to make helium
these nuclear reactions release vast
amounts of energy in the form of
sunlight
if only we could work out how to harness
this
but we are getting there
it's estimated that by 2022 30 of our
energy could come from renewables with
solar growing faster than anything else
the sun is vast dynamic and sometimes
violent
viewed up close the sun's surface looks
like a raging sea of fire with huge
eruptions rising hundreds of thousands
of kilometers into space
there are even earthquakes on the sun
called sun quakes
and what happens on the sun can impact
us the sun sporadically blasts huge
clouds of charged particles towards the
earth potentially wreaking havoc on the
technology that we all rely on but 97 of
people have never heard of solar storms
in 1859 a gigantic solar storm hit the
earth
creating auroras that covered the entire
planet
knocking out the telegraph network and
sending sparks flying from electrical
equipment the solar storm of 1859 is
still the largest on record but if a
similar storm were to hit the earth
today the consequences for our way of
life could be devastating
knocking out electricity grids satellite
navigation and communications for days
weeks or even months
no wonder people used to worship the sun
[Music]
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video